- В школі я більш-менш
знав англійську мову.
От, і коли я прийшов до інституту,
то рівень моєї англійської
мови отак-от пішов на спад.
- Клас! Англійська мова,
якраз що, дуже потрібна.
Мені в житті вона відкрила багато дверей.
Hello again!
My name is Nataliia Liashko and
it’s time for English lesson. Let’s start!
And I would like to welcome
my star-students today!
Hello Alina! - Hello Natalia.
- How are you today?
- I'm great, thank you so much.
- It’s nice.
- How are you Alex?
- Well.
- You're well? That’s good.
- Would you like to ask me?
- How old are you?
- How old are you? Wow,
that’s a nice question. Okay…
- I think it’s not very
nice to ask straight away.
This is a very interesting
question for man.
- They want to know?
- Yes. I'm in my thirties, okay?
- Today we’ll talk about transport.
- Okay.
- Let’s go!
This is a text we are going to read.
Unfortunately, my kid destroyed it.
But have a look at the text.
And try not to read word-by-word.
What do you think is the text about?
- The train station?
- Train station, okay. Anything else?
- Okay, and there are
some comments of people.
Jackie Beal, Kelly, Alex. And uhm….
- Does it look like a blog for you?
Or a piece of information
from the internet?
- Yeah it can be because
we can see the information,
opening hours, entrance,
or adult or children.
Or maybe it’s like a train
station-museum or something.
- Museum, yes.
So, this is about museum.
And if we talk about transport, so
probably this is about transport museum.
Any ideas where is it?
- Where it is?
- Yeah, where is it, which country?
- We should find something?
- I'm gonna help you.
- Okay, come on. Alright.
- London!
- Transport Museum.
- Bravo! Amazing! This is a museum.
So, let’s have a look at the full text.
We’ll talk about London Transport Museum.
Okay?
We’ll read the text and
I’ll ask you five questions.
You can answer the question using:
true, false or No-Answer answers. Okay?
- Okay.
- True is correct, false is not correct
and No-Answer means that we don’t
have the information in the text. Okay?
- Alright. Should we read everything?
- No, we start with the question.
I give you the question
and then you look through the text
and give me the answer. Let’s try.
Number 1: so, children
pay to enter the museum.
Try to find this information.
Alina?
- I can see the information.
Children – free.
Entrance for children is free.
- Absolutely right. Entrance:
children – free. Correct.
Number two?
- True... it’s false I mean.
- So, the museum is not open on Fridays.
What is the answer.
The museum is not open on Fridays.
- I can have an answer.
- Okay, Alina.
- Can I? - Yes.
- I see the information.
Friday, we see three
letters, from 11 until 18.
- Yes.
So, the museum is open on Monday-Thursday.
Saturday-Sunday and Friday specifically.
Right.
So, the next question. I guess this
question is going to be to Alex. Okay?
- Я просто в тексті шукав.
- It’s okay, it’s okay.
We can find information
in all of the text, even here.
This can help you.
- Okay, Nataliia.
- So, ready?
Let’s go.
The collection of London
buses is the best in the UK.
- Collection of London buses…
- … is the best in the UK.
It’s a really interesting question.
Okay.
True, False?
- We don’t have this information.
- So, if we don’t have the information?
- No answer.
- No answer, yes. Because we can’t see.
Number four, next question:
visitors can walk there
from a train station.
Visitors can walk there
Try to find the information with us.
- … seven minutes from
Charing Cross railway station.
- So?
- We can get there. Right?
- So, the answer is true or false?
- А, он, внизу.
- So, Alex, it’s?
- It’s true!
- Bravo, amazing!
And let’s see.
So, we can walk on foot
and it’s very close to the tube station
and to Charing Cross railway station.
- Yeah.
- The last question. Number five:
I'm gonna give you a hint.
The information is here.
The answer is here, in
this part, at the bottom.
- The comments of these people. - Yes.
Schools take classes to the museum?
True, false or no answer?
- Oh, wait.
Can you tell us…
- Schools take classes to the museum.
So, it means that they have it
like an excursion to the museum.
- So, Jackie Beal said the correct answer.
- Yes, so she says that she
was there on a school day. Right?
On a school outing on Friday. So, it’s?
- True.
- So, let’s check the answers.
Students say to enter the museum – false.
The museum is not open on Friday – false.
The collection of London buses
is the best in the UK – no answer.
Visitors can walk there
from a train station – true.
And schools can take
classes to the museum – true.
Yeah.
So, let’s have a look at the
transport that we’re gonna use today.
And we have eight pictures. Let’s
start with number one - what’s this?
Bus?
- Bravo, Alex! Number two?
- Helicopter.
- Amazing! Number three?
- Motorbike.
- Motorbike! Or motorcycle,
it’s possible as well.
- Number four. What’s this?
- Ship.
- Yes, this is a ship.
Number five?
- Taxi.
- Okay, it’s taxi. Six?
- Train.
- Seven?
- Trolleybus.
- Oh, no, not a trolleybus, it’s.
- “Elektrichka”
- It’s not “elektrichka”.
- Electrobus?
- Tram.
- Tram! And…?
- Plane.
- Plane. Yes, fantastic. So, let’s
check. Correct! Well done guys!
- Cool!
- Okay, now you are going to
hear the sound of the transport.
And you need to tell me, which of
the means of transport you can hear.
Okay? - Aha, wow.
- So, let’s start with number one but
please, listen carefully to the end
and then I will ask you, and you
tell me the means of transport. Okay?
- Okay, what's this? Alina?
- It’s motorcycle!
- Look like your favourite.
- Yeah, my father got one.
- Let’s go with another one. Alex? Plane.
- Okay. And the next one.
Alina
- A train.
- A train?
- Tram?
- Probably a tram. Can be both.
- Can be both.
- Alex?
- Helicopter.
- Helicopter, bravo!
So, now a task for you.
You need to unscramble the words.
So, the letters are mixed, okay?
We’ll do it one by one.
- We’ll start with Alex and then we’ll go
with Alina. Alex, number one, what’s this?
- Ship. Amazing! Number two?
- Bus.
- But word itself is
correct, actually – USB.
- Can be.
- But we talk about transport.
- Yes, this is different
topic, exactly. Alex?
- Helicopter.
- Correct. Next one, Alina?
- Train.
- Bravo!
- Цей, мотоцикл, чи що?
- Aha, how to say this
in English? Motorcycle.
- Yes, correct.
- Tram.
- Good. And the last one?
- Plane?
- Yes, correct! Okay, now
we’ll play a game, do you mind?
- With pleasure.
And this is going to be a
competition between Alex and Alina.
Who will win?
Let’s see.
So, we are going to use
the words of the transport.
Do you remember? Eight words.
What was there?
- Yeah. A plane, a train, a tram,
a helicopter, a motorcycle, a ship…
Don’t you remember?
- Продовжуй-продовжуй.
- Helicopter, did I say it already?
Helicopter and the
eight one, the last one…
- Taxi. - Taxi!
- Taxi, yeah. So, let’s imagine
that this is our bus, okay?
And it needs to go to the station. Okay?
Let’s say that this is the station.
And these are the stops.
When your answer is correct,
I move the bus.
So, your task is actually to
bring the bus to the station.
- To get to the point.
- Yes. If your answer is not correct,
wrong – the bus goes back. Unfortunately.
- Ah, so it will have a step back.
- It will move, yes.
So, I’ll be giving you the words.
one, two, three, four letters in the word.
And you need to guess the word.
You can’t tell me the word,
you can name only letters.
A, B, D, L, O. Okay?
You are guessing the letters and if
the letter is correct – the bus moves.
Okay?
So, let’s try to guess the word.
Alex or Alina, who will win?
We’ll start with ladies first.
- Can I? Okay.
- So, the first letter…
- T.
- T, yes, correct. And the bus moves.
- R?
- R. Sorry, no R. Oops, it goes back.
Alex, you have your turn
because Alina lost her turn.
- I?
- Yes, correct.
- Uh-oh… O?
- No O, sorry.
- Alina, your turn.
- It’s gonna be one of those words, right?
- Yes.
- Ah, X?
- X, yes, correct. So, it goes down.
- And the last one?
- A.
- A, bravo! So, the word is taxi.
First point to you, Alina.
That’s nice, so the score is zero-one.
We’ll see.
A new word, ready?
one, two, three, four, five letters.
Five letters.
So, we start with Alex, don’t you mind?
- Of course.
- Alex, please give me a letter.
- A.
- A, yes, correct. And the bus moves.
- Зараз, я подумаю.
- Just a second.
- L?
- Yes, correct.
- P.
- Yes, P.
- Ну, Р українська.
- Bravo! P.
- N?
- Yes.
- E.
- Yes! And the score is
one-one. It’s a plane! Amazing!
- So, we don’t have a winner.
When there is one-one,
we say “дружба”, yes?
So, in English this is draw.
- Draw? A draw.
- Like bro?
- Or a tie – як краватка.
- Draw.
- Draw or a tie.
It’s nice.
So, if we have a look at
these transports, let’s discuss,
which transport is fast
and which one is slow.
- But you need to tell me, you
need to give me a sentence.
For example: I think taxi is slow.
Or fast.
Okay?
Give me the full sentence.
So, who wants to start?
We’ll start with start and slow first.
Fast and slow.
- Сan? Yes please.
- I think that helicopter
is a fast transport.
- It’s fast, okay. Is it the fastest?
- In some point, when we are
in the mountains – yes. For sure.
- Aha, okay, so you
think that helicopter is fast.
Alex, what about you? What do you think?
- I think plane is fast.
- Okay, good.
- What is slow? What do
you think is the slowest?
- Tram?
- The tram is the slowest?
- Can be.
- Can be. Depends on the situation.
- Or a ship?
- Ship can be quite slow as
well when they are cruising.
- Or a bus if we are having a…
- Traffic jam?
- Traffic jam, yeah.
- Oh, okay, well.
I think, when there is a traffic jam
every single mean of transport is so slow.
- But not the helicopter or plane!
- Yeah, so it’s prioritizing.
- Or a motorcycle.
- Motorcycle is also possible.
But the best one for traffic
jam is bicycle, I guess. Agree?
- But we don’t have it here.
- So, exciting or boring.
Exciting? Or boring?
So, let’s discuss this
thing, these criteria.
- Alina?
- I can say that the
train is exciting for me.
Because I like to read or watch something.
- Okay, what do you usually
do on the train when you travel?
Apart from reading.
- I read some books.
- Okay.
- I like to read books
or to drink classic tea.
- Okay.
- In Ukrainian train.
- It’s the Ukrainian tea.
- I love Ukrainian train, tea. It’s
like the classic thing, tradition.
- Perfect.
- With some sweets.
- So, this is like a habit
for you. A part of a routine.
- To get from Kyiv to my land – it’s
like 16 hours. So, I'm enjoying the time.
- Yes, I understand this.
What about you, Alex?
- Так, значить я…
- Exciting or boring?
- Boring – tram. Буду
настоювати на своєму.
- Why do you think that tram is
boring? It’s not interesting at all?
- You’ve never been in a party-tram.
- No.
- Party-tram is nice, I guess it can
be. And we also can have a party-bus.
- Yeah.
- We can have a party-bus as well. Okay.
Relaxing or tiring.
So, relaxing trip.
This is – you enjoy your trip, you
leave the transport very relaxed
or tiring, exhausting.
You don’t have any feelings.
- So, can I answer?
- Yes, Alina.
- I didn’t use so much the
ship to go somewhere very far.
But plane, for sure, yes.
And it’s tiring for me because
it’s really like all these moments.
To give your documents, after – wait.
After – do that and that.
Yeah, so it’s tiring for
me but it’s really fast
because you can get to another country.
- And sometimes this is the only possible
connection – with the plane. Right?
- Yeah, right.
- And this can also be very tiring
if you have a connection flight
and you need to stay in
the airport and wait, and wait.
- Yeah, I got a lot of stories.
- What about you, Alex?
What’s for you relaxing or tiring?
- Tiring – it’s tram.
- Tram is your favourite.
- Yeah.
- Do you remember the
last day you were on a tram?
- Never.
- You definitely need to try it.
- I hate tram.
- You hate trams? It’s a pity.
This can be nice.
- We’re gonna get him to Podil party-tram.
- Okay, so let’s schedule the meeting.
Okay.
Now, let’s have a look at this
transport in terms of cheap or expensive.
And let’s rank.
Rank means that number one is the cheapest
and number eight, because we
have eight means of transport,
is the most expensive one.
Okay? - Okay.
- So, let’s go and…
Eight numbers.
- My opinion – it’s gonna
be the answer of Alex.
- Tram.
- Trammm.
- So, tram is the cheapest
you think? Both agree?
- Yeah.
- Good.
- After – I’ll put the bus.
- Bus! Yeah.
- The next one?
- Bus.
- A bus.
- Next one – a taxi.
- Yeah.
- Sure?
- I think…
- Okay. Taxi.
- After – it can be…
- Train.
- Train. Okay.
- So, to have a trip on a ship,
maybe it can be expensive.
But what is about motorcycle?
How is it going?
To buy a motorcycle – it’s expensive.
- You tell me, you are the bosses
here, you decide where to put motorcycle.
- Шо ти сказала?
- I think that ship…
- Думаєш так?...
- … To buy a ticket – it
can be cheap. Right?
- Okay. Ship. Let’s put a ship.
- Next one is the ship. Okay, ship.
- After – let’s put as low-cost plane.
Can be.
Because I think helicopter
is the most expensive to get.
- Yeah. Okay.
- Let’s put the… yeah, plane.
After – motorcycle to buy.
- Motorcycle to buy, not
the petrol. Motorcycle to buy.
- To buy. Yes, to buy a motorcycle.
- And the most expensive?
- The helicopter.
- Helicopter. Would you
like to use a helicopter?
- Yeah, I would love to.
- What about you, Alex? Have
you ever? Or a private tram for you?
- Tram is disgusting.
- Disgusting, agree.
Actually, tram is very limited.
Where you can go?
You need rails for that.
Helicopter can go any way.
Right? Anywhere.
- So, let’s move on.
Now it’s quiz time.
And I'm going to check you.
Ready for a little test?
- Let’s try.
- Okay, let’s try.
So, the first question:
London Transport Museum works
every day – correct? Or not correct?
- Correct.
- Correct and it’s true.
The next question:
London Transport Museum
was opened in 1990s.
- Not correct.
- Yes, it’s false.
- 1916 maybe, yeah?
- 16 or 60s?
- 60s.
- Good, bravo. This is correct.
See, this is how it works.
You pay attention to details.
Next question:
London transport Museum is not far
from the Coven Garden tube station.
- Correct.
- Correct?
- I think.
- Let’s check.
Well done, Alina!
This is amazing.
And one more quick test.
Name these means of
transport. We’ll start with Alex.
- Ship, tram, helicopter, motorcycle.
- Good, Alina, correct?
- Really correct. It’s
like – he’s banging!
- Yes! 12 балів.
- 12 балів, точно.
- Дякую.
- Correct, see!
So, guys, it’s time for your homework.
At home: rank the means
of transport that we use today
and from one – it’s the slowest,
to eight – which is the fastest.
Okay?
And I'm gonna check
you next time, next lesson.
Unfortunately – there is a bell
and we need to stop the lesson.
So, thank you very much!
- Thank you, Nataliia!
- Thank you!
- See you next time!
Так, я сьогодні був на уроці
англійської мови за шостий клас.
Чесно кажучи, я дуже сильно переживав,
тому що
я думав, що зараз будуть щось питати таке,
я не буду нічого знати і я осоромлюсь.
З сьогоднішньою ситуацією, яка склалася, я
скажу відверто про себе – я вчусь онлайн.
Я маю купу розписаних уроків онлайн.
І це, насправді, дуже зручно.
І це можна дуже класно організувати.
Звісно ж, спочатку тобі
незручно і ти не звик.
Але потім…
Плюс діти зараз, вони
звикли до діджитал-світу.
Тому, для них, мені здається –
це буде зрозуміла річ.
Тому, я дуже сподіваюсь, що це буде таким
популярним, класним дійством для них.
У нас все вийшло.
Ми старались.
І ви старайтесь.
Хто буде дивитись – старайтесь.
Це – не складно.